Votons le neuf/06 prochain pour 1 seule et même liste,
faisons des lives, faisons des vidéos,
mettons-nous d'accord les muslims de France,
mettons-nous d'accord
contre les sionistes et contre les racistes
et contre les génocidaires,
par amour pour nos frères palestiniens.
Tous les musulmans de France
vote pour 1 seule et même liste politique
aux prochaines élections européennes le neuf/06,
le neuf/06 deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Si tous les musulmans de France, à travers
TikTok, à travers les réseaux sociaux,
on se mettait d'accord pour voter
pour 1 seule et même liste pro-palestinienne
et antisioniste,
c'est 1 idée qui a été développée dans son live.
Il faut qu'elle se
que qu'on la développe,
que chacun l'entende. Si nous, on se mettait d'accord,
on est,
les musulmans sont les grands perdants de France,
on nous maîtrise,
on nous regarde de haut,
on nous juge, on nous rabaisse et surtout
on massacre nos femmes, nos enfants, nos anciens,
nos frères dans la bande de Gaza et en 6 jordanis.
Votons le neuf/06 prochain pour 1 seule et même liste.
Faisons des lives,
faisons des vidéos, mettons-nous d'accord
les muslims de France,
mettons-nous d'accord
contre les sionistes et contre les racistes
et contre les génocidaires,
par amour pour nos frères palestiniens.